[Music]
this weekend mesquite is gonna be a car
lover's paradise with the 2021 super run
car show and here to tell us all about
it is christian with the casablanca
resort who is sponsoring this segment
christian it's great to see you buddy
great to see you again all right let's
talk about how many cars you're gonna
have there this weekend yeah we're gonna
have over 600 cars at the casa blanca
resort this weekend so if you're a car
fan you've got to get to mesquite this
weekend okay let's talk about some of
these cars here what's the one we're
looking at right here so this is a 1970
chrysler 300 hearst this is one of two
wow one of two cars now if someone's
watching and they want to register the
car is there still availability to bring
your car down absolutely bring your car
up to the kosplunk resort this weekend
you can register your car on site and we
got over 260 prizes or 15 000 in cash
and prizes this weekend let's keep
walking you always bring so many great
cars when you come down to talk about
the show now what are some of the events
that are taking place with the cars this
weekend i think it's a great thing about
our car show is you get to see not only
these beautiful cars but you can see
them in action like this my ford mustang
right here 700 plus horsepower and we're
going to have open header cruises
throughout the town uh roaring ending
competitions uh slow drags so you can
see what's under the hood and some
beautiful cars as well now this is a gt
500 shelby super snake i i've met you
before what's the fastest if you had the
car about 165 what and this was on the
track door this is not on the 215. of
course not
let's head down here we have some more
cars to check out uh down here now
christian people are watching it's a
three-day event talk to me about room
packages do you have anything available
absolutely we have rooms available but
i'll tell you what just like these cars
they're going fast so go to
customwalkerresort.com
get your room for this weekend bring the
whole family up it's free to the family
to attend and the best part is too you
get to vote for your favorite car and it
goes towards people's choice for the
awards i i went there the last show you
had a couple months back it was a blast
it was a great time there's also vendors
out there during the show what are some
of the vendors you're going to have yeah
we have some great food and beverage
vendors but also you know we have parts
corral up there so if you're a car fan
need that little you know part for your
car we have some vendors up there to
take good care of you and you mentioned
it it's free for everyone and the
judging takes place all weekend and when
do you announce the winners yeah we're
going to have the awards in the
koscielnka showroom sunday at four
o'clock so get up there all weekend long
your vote counts up to four o'clock on
sunday and we're gonna give away some
great awards like i said fifteen
thousand dollars in cash and prizes for
these great vehicles get their hands on
this weekend okay so everyone that has a
fancy car they got a nickname for the
car what's your nickname for your car
speed plus speed speed is perfect thank
you so much thank you don't forget our
parade at 12 o'clock on saturday friday
and saturday there's a parade on a car
parade a car parade check it out all
right christian run down the details
really fast website and phone number
absolutely go to superrun.com or
casablanca resort.com book your room
this weekend 877-438-2929
come to see all these great cars like i
said if you're a car fan you've got to
be at the casablanca resort this weekend
fantastic christian thank you so much
rocky we'll send it back to you in the
studio